madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
Ministre Ministre
collègu vous nous avez maintenu dans
l'attente Monsieur le Premier Ministre
plus de de semaines avant de vous
entendre délivrer un discours de
politique générale que vous devez à la
représentation nationale bien entendu
vous ne demandez pas la confiance à
l'Assemblée ce qui serait le minimum que
l'on pourrait attendre si notre
démocratie fonctionnait vous ne demandez
pas la confiance car vous ne l'avez pas
vous n'avez ni la confiance de
l'Assemblée ni celle des citoyens vous
nous avez maintenu dans l'attente mais
vous vous êtes rendu compte entretemps
que personne ne vous attendait les
agriculteurs en colère ne vous ont pas
attendu pour lancer un mouvement pour
vivre de leur travail leur avez-vous dit
que votre majorité avait rejeté une loi
que nous avions proposé en novembre
dernier pour encadrer les marges de
l'industrie agroalimentaire et surtout
garantir des prix rémunérateurs pour eux
leur avez-vous parlé de votre duplicité
oou vous êtes-vous contenté d'une mise
en scène poussive pathétique et
immédiatement échoué entre une botte de
faim et un vert de vin rouge sur une
autoroute beaucoup de communication ne
font pas une politique vous venez
d'ailleurs encore une fois de le montrer
avec votre discours de propagande
générale les professeurs ne vous ont pas
davantage attendu ils seront en grève ce
jeudi 1er février épuisé par
l'application de vos improvisations
ministérielles et atterré par la
nouvelle ministre qu'Emmanuel Macron et
vous-même leur avez choisi cette
nouvelle ministre est à elle seule un
symbole de l'ensemble de votre
gouvernement de vos politiques passées
et à venir elle donne votre adresse de
classe oligarchie c'est par ici haute
bourgeoisie vous y voilà fille du
directeur de Publicis femme du directeur
général de la Société générale puis de
sanofille cousine d'une éditorialiste de
BFM TV nièise d'une éditorialiste bien
connue du service public présidente de
la Fédération française de tennis pour
500000 € par an avant de devenir
ministre des Sports puis tout récemment
de l'éducation nationale des sports des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques la
pauvre nous disait-elle elle gagnait
trois fois plus à
merci de nous avoir offert une si belle
caricature de votre politique de
l'oligarchie que vous êtes représenté et
défendeé quand on lui parle de sa
défense lamentable de ses mensonges à
répétition dans cette affère du L
Stanislas où des thèses réactionnaires
et hostiles à la République sont répandu
elle dit ne pas avoir menti non
tenez-vous bien c'est la réalité qui lui
donne tort en la matière vous êtes des
experts en matière de politique
soci d'écologie de démocratie la réalité
vous donne toujours tort mais vous
continuez la réalité vous donne encore
tort vous continuez vous mentez de
nouveau vous continuez Monsieur le
Premier Ministre madame oua Castera
partage avec vous un arrondissement du
LCÉE Stanislas à l'École alsacienne on
se comprend bien entre grand
bourgeois madame ou castira n'est pas
encore partie pour une bonne raison vous
êtes tous comme elle alors pourquoi
serait à l'elle de s'en aller la
première elle p ne devoir rien à
personne et sans doute doit-elle vivre
son ministère comme une peine infinie
car elle y gagne encore moins qu'à la
Fédération Française de Tennis peut-être
peut-être les effets cumulés de votre
suppression de l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune compensent-t-il toutefois
cette perte de revenus
ouf Monsieur le Premier Ministre
l'étymologie de ministre est simple
permettez-moi de vous la rappeler ce nom
vient de ministère serviteur en latin
tout gouvernement doit être un
gouvernement de serviteur vous êtes un
gouvernement de serviteurs sans un doute
mais vous ignorez qu'en démocratie c'est
le peuple que les ministres doivent
servir au lieu de cela vous vous servez
vous-même et les plus riches dont les
intérêts ne se sont jamais aussi bien
portés en 5e République que sous
Emmanuel Macron la fortune des 500
familles les plus riches de ce pays a
plus que doublé depuis 2017 vous en êtes
les serviteurs aés mais vous oubliez la
République et ses principes vous
préférer jeter en pâure celles et ceux
qui arrivent sur notre territoire pour
ne pas parler des inégalit croissante du
problème massif du lovement des
sansabriis des travailleurs si nombreux
dont la paix ne suffit plus de la
situation sociale insupportable que vos
politiques injustes font subir au pays
vous n'êtes monsieur le Premier ministre
à la hauteur ni de la situation sociale
ni de notre histoire démocratique et
encore moins de l'impérative nécessité à
transformer nos modes de production pour
répondre à l'immense défi écologique
vous n'êtes pas à la
hauteur une partie de la presse
sympathisante sans doute de votre gouver
minoritaire P des portraits ridicules de
vous Monsieur le Premier Ministre où
l'on s'extasie du fait que vous dormiez
peu c'est peut-être pour cela que le
pays semble conduit par une équipe de
somnambule ensommeillé dans leur rêve de
milliardaires éblouis par les lumières
télévisuelles vivant dans un spectacle
permanent que le pays regarde avec
consternation mais pendant que vous
vivez de l'esbrouff éternelle le pays
souffre vos tentatives d'hypnose ne
fonctionnent pas les agriculteurs à bout
comprennent que le libre échange la
défense par une poignée d'un modèle
intennable les marges les est sans
contrôle sont la source de leur
difficultés quotidiennes les enseignants
voient se créer vos groupes de
niveau idée aussi stigmatisant
qu'ineefficace sur le plan pédagogique
comprennent le caractère systématique de
la destruction du service public qu'ils
honorent les chemineaux que vous avez
vilipandé dont vous avez dégradé la
condition social voit disparaître à
petit feu le service public ferroviaire
que vous avez détruit méthodiquement
pour libérer le rail conformément aux
directives européennes les salariés du
privé souffrent toujours davantage du
partage violemment injuste de la valeur
produitite les soignants et personnels
du secteur médico-social constatent en
dépit de leur engagement quotidien votre
obstination à mettre en pièce le service
public de la santé les chômeurs Patis à
chacune de vos réformes d'avantage de la
violence que vous leur infligez et de la
situation économique qui leur laisse le
choix entre la précarité ou la honte que
vos discours d'exclusion leur renvoie
toujours jour les jeunes pour le climat
voit votre incompréhension totale de
l'ampleur des changements nécessaires
pour faire face au dérèglements
climatiques et à l'extinction de masse
des espèces les retraités s'inquiète des
coups de canif que vous avez mis dans le
contrat social qui unit entre elles les
générations notre magnifique système de
retraite par répatition Monsieur le
Premier Ministre c'est le peuple tout
entier qui n'en peut plus de vos
politiques elles ont toutes la même
source le refus d'engager le partage des
richesses pour rémunérer le travail
engager les investissements nécessaires
pour les bifurcation écologique et
reconstruire nos services publics vous
déstabilisez profondément notre société
en vous en vous les éloignant loin bien
loin de la République sociale vous
resterez dans l'histoire comme le
pouvoir qui a ramené la France à un pays
qui a faim à un pays où les gens meurent
de la rue meurent du travail meurent sur
des brancards
d'hpitaux une alternative existe
monsieur le Premier ministre et le fait
que vous ne demandiez pas la confiance
en est la preuve vous êtes minoritair
vous le savez vous nous avez fait
attendre mais personne n'attend plus
rien de vous à vous et aux citoyens qui
nous écoute à cette heure je l'affirme
une alternative existe oui il est
possible d'engager une toute autre
politique augmenter le SMIG à 1600 € net
convoquer une conférence générale
d'augmentation des salaires porter l'âge
de la retraite à 60 ans pour 40 annuité
investir massivement dans les services
publics dans l'isolation thermique des
logements les énergies renouvelables
dans un pôle public de l'énergie ou
encore dans la formation et
l'installation de nouveaux paysans comme
l'annulation de la dette des agriculteur
pour la conversion sociale et écologique
tout cela est possible alors je vous
entends déjà comment accomplir et
financer cela c'est simple en cessant de
servir ce que vous servez en taxant le
capital en rétablissement l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune en créant de
nouvelles tranches d'impôts sur le
revenu pour les plus riches de notre
pays en rendant progressive la
contribution sociale généralisée en un
mot en organisant le partage des
richesses une telle perspective peut
vous sembler abominable mais c'est
pourtant la clé de la cohésion du pays
aujourd'hui vous en êtes le facteur de
division abusant des pouvoirs que vous
donne l'actuelle Constitution la 5e
République vous rend d'ailleurs plus
invisible que vous le souhaiteriez sans
doute Monsieur le Premier Ministre
personne n'ignore que tout se décide à
l'Élysée jusqu'au discours que vous
venez de prononcer Monsieur le Premier
Ministre relu anoté et corrigé par le
monarque lui-même Emmanuel Macron et le
serviteur en chef et vous êtes à ces
ordres comme d'ailleurs une bonne partie
de la minorité parlementaire qui a crub
bon de voter il y a quelques semaines
une loi reprenant le principe de
préférence nationale défendu par
Jean-Marie Le Pen et ses héritiers
siégeant sur ses bancs un argument
avancé alors vaut qu'on le retienne
certaines dispositions devaient être
votées car elles étaient
antionstitutionnelles et seraient donc
censuré par la suite nous vous nous nous
demandons parfois si vous vous rendez
compte du caractère planant de certains
de vos arguments ne cro croyez-vous pas
qu'un tel mépris pour nos règles
communes soit le signe d'un épuisement
de nos institutions la situation
politique don actuelle dont vous êtes un
sous prododuit invite fortement à mettre
sur la table un changement
institutionnel une autre politique est
possible une autre République est
possible pour renouer avec la République
sociale avec notre belle devise Liberté
Égalité Fraternité il est temps de
convoquer une constituante et de rédiger
la Constitution de la 6e république la
République de l'intervention citoyenne
du référendum révocatoire qui sil éta
mis en place permettrait aux Français de
retourner aux urnes alors que vous le
refusez obstinément en dépit de l'état
de crise permanent dans lequel vous
plongez le pays la République de
l'intérêt général enfin une République
où les ministres servent le peuple et
pas une oligarchie de plus en plus
déconnectée vivement un nouveau
gouvernement d'union populaire
organisant ce partage des richesses la
bifurcation écologique et le retour à la
démocratie dans notre pays a besoin nous
y sommes prêts avec détermination nous
préparons l'alternative à votre monde de
malheur monsieur Premier ministre
emporte avec vous en guise
d'avertissement cette phrase du
philosophe Maurice merlopanti qui disait
le pouvoir qu'on appelle légitime et
celui qui réussit à éviter le mépris et
la haine depuis 2017 et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui vous n'avez réussi à éviter
ni l'un ni
l'autre je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente